i remember when we had uh we saw uh joe
rogan had bob lazar on right yeah
those are not familiar he's this dude
who what was he a contractor right
yes and then he worked at maison physics
facility for a brief time in 81. he said
that he saw like this this like machine
like there's like an object where he
couldn't get his hands like it was a
force field almost something like that
do you think that guy was telling the
truth well
i've done a lot of investigations into
bob um enough actually a friend of mine
named dan banker
right uh about 50 minutes north of here
in pa he did a lot of
a lot of this research and he's really
good friends with john lear and george
knapp
and all those guys from the original
story and stuff
and the bob lazar case is an interesting
case
but we've done a ton of research on on
it and
you know we look at the actionable
intelligence and the science and stuff
and you know what we call element 115
and this in sort of our jargon is uh
what's called unobtainium
and unobtainium is like saying that oh
well you can have anti-gravity but it's
this element that can only be created in
supernovas and really
really far galaxies and we can't create
it in our
you know labs and stuff it's basically
saying that yeah you can have
anti-gravity but you need this
high hanging fruit that you'll never
ever reach it's kind of the idea with
with that element 115 story
that's what he was saying there's a lot
of controversy with that story they said
that he predicted element 115
it's not that hard to predict higher
elements in the periodic table it's
literally arithmetic you're literally
just adding protons you know it's anyone
who can add
so i i heard that there's uh i was just
writing
oh sorry i want to go back on bob lazar
but uh but bob lazor we'd like to invite
bob
actually to apec you know if because
i've never seen bob give an interview
with any scientist he's never given
interviews with physicists it's always
like it always seems like the interviews
he does gives are controlled and all the
questions are pre-screened and stuff
no way joe pre-screened any of that
stuff no that's too much
that's like that's not the kind of first
two hour long conversation
i had a lot of people like saying that
oh he's involved with a deal with
netflix and that he's getting paid to
promote this because
let's face it after bob is laura was on
joe rogan his film on netflix got like a
million hits
sure sure but like i know joe there's no
way joe was like here's a list of
like they gave him a list of questions
nah he wouldn't do that i mean even the
best actor would
remember two hours of script but but let
me just he's been saying it for
30 years no no for sure for sure but
like joe could ask whatever he wants
like but he doesn't know what to ask he
only got into the case recently
but that's that's just a safe interview
for bob then right you know what i mean
like
they put bob in a situation where they
know that joe as a layman is going to
ask only safe questions based on what
he's what he's seeing on the tv
he's really curious that he's he he got
an opportunity
right after he came out in like the
early 90s to present
and before stanford university to a team
of physicists and he turned that down
he also initially said that there was an
alien remember that
his initial story was that he saw an
alien and later said it must have been a
puppet
and i'm like why say that anyway did
they really do that i don't know if i
believe it
i feel like they wanted to feed this guy
disinformation they had him working on
like high-tech drones that they had
recovered from tesla tech or that they'd
been working on since they raided
tesla's office
and they invited these scientists in
there like just in case they go rogue
we're going to feed them a bunch of crap
so that they look like idiots we're
going to tell them it came from zeta
reticuli that there's a new element that
you can't find
and that there's aliens involved well
there's lots of theories you know
well like i was just saying the the joke
from the menos derek goats where it's
like the russians think we did it
because the french started a rumor and
then we denied it but they think we're
lying
it's like with bob lazar he tells the
story uh if those aren't familiar with
this story
there's a documentary about it many of
you are probably familiar with joe rogan
and he talked about how he
saw all of this tech this crazy
technology anti-gray i saw aliens and
then later said was that maybe a puppet
or something
but many people speculate what if it was
a potemkin research base
that the idea was bring in this
contractor bring in a bunch of them
show them very ridiculous magic tricks
tell them it's real so they believe it
and then wait for one of them to leak it
that way
our enemies at the time russia the
soviet union would hear the u.s has
crazy weapons better not attack them
because they got anti-grav and they're
working with the aliens
do you know the russians after after bob
lazar came out they spent about
uh a billion dollars looking into
element 115 and trying to create super
heavy elements
the russians did the russians created
element 115 it's called moscovium
right because it was it was discovered
in in moscow what does what can it do
can it make you it has about a 32 second
you know half-life and it decays and and
it doesn't it
there's no stable isotope like bob
claimed yet found
if there is one tomorrow then i you know
but right now we don't but right now we
don't have that
well the u.s government has a long
history of playing psychological tricks
and we'll just think about this on their
scientists that work with them
so the real secrets they wouldn't allow
to leak out okay well depends um
i mean we can't make definitive
statements like that because again
anything's possible right yeah or they
leak it or they
or they bury it 30 years later it would
be buried i'm just saying disinformation
is something that the us government uses
many times and they steer scientists
tell them they're working on one thing
when they're working on another that was
the manhattan
exactly exactly and it could be that bob
lazar was told
certain things that weren't true but his
story was that he was
a part of a team trying to reverse
engineer this alien technology that was
given to them
right and one scientist doesn't do it
another scientist is going to try and
they keep swapping him in him out
that's the story just for he was working
on like eight different craft i think he
said he saw eight different different
shapes of craft right there's a lot of
lot of there's a big long story there's
a lot of details involved and stuff and
like like i said we go after actionable
intelligence
the research i did into s4 i found that
there's no evidence of a base at papoose
lake we have the satellite photos of the
of the facility that's never been
touched
going back decades so that we haven't
found evidence of a base at papua's lake
but we did find a site for which is that
tonopah test range which is like
literally right next to area 51 so a lot
on a lot of these maps that show like
area 51 and s4
they're really talking about site 4
which is at tonopah which is where a ton
of these
you know electronic counter measures and
other technologies were worked on this
is where you know they built the
and flew the f-117 and and the stealth
fighter and the bombers and stuff
so i saw a story not that long ago a
couple months ago and it was talking
about these strange
sightings of strange vehicles appearing
near a naval base
and the funny thing was it was like we
you know these soldiers are saying they
see it
and they're they're reporting when
they're doing these training missions
they see these strange craft
and now they're publishing it everyone's
like this is it there's aliens
and then they casually mention in all
these articles that only you know 70
miles away is an advanced naval research
base
and i'm like so what they're saying
they're just they're just seeing
aircraft made by themselves
is it and they're not they're not high
enough security clearance and know what
it is so they record it
and then why is it that so many higher
ups would dismiss the stories initially
because the stories apparently was that
they were finally now going to take
these claims seriously
in case there's a security threat well
listen if you're higher up
and then you hear a story was like i saw
a crazy vehicle and you're thinking
yourself yeah
the research base is 50 miles away
they're flying something around you
wouldn't care
you'd ignore it that could be a weakness
for us because it really could be an
external threat
so maybe it's good they're actually
looking into it but it also could be
just completely
redundant oh yeah we better investigate
ourselves for the project we're working
is it possible that there are craft that
are so lightweight and that are being
moved around
like by a laser or by a magnet or
something
all right so there's lots of different
technologies there's a guy in from nasa
um lightcraft international he started a
company his name is
leek miraboo it's l-e-i-k m-y-r-a-b-o
and uh he was working on exactly where
you're talking about
microwave purple craft where they
actually fire it was called project sky
vault
and they fire microwaves at um beamed
craft
and uh light craft and they're able to
like and they develop this into a
technology where they can actually like
blast these um and ionize the air
surfaces flowing across wings of
aircraft so they can literally move the
aircraft and take control of the
aircraft by
like warping the air currents around the
aircraft themselves so they can take
control of like
there's a whole patent we have on taking
control of an enemy aircraft using this
microwave lasers to ionize the gas of
the air going across their wings to
disrupt its flight and then also there's
what are called phase conjugate mirrors
which are really strange
optical property and they have radar
absorbent paint made out of these kinds
of materials in fact like the paint that
they used on the
stealth fighters was actually a meta
material made of barium titanate and
they actually mixed it in the paint so
that it was radar absorbent
and um so that not appear on radar i
thought i thought the goal of stealth
was that it
it looked like a bird right it's that
cross-sectional
they basically the goal is they took
that formula for the cross-sectional
radar area of
of a object and they figured out how to
minimize
the the parts of it to in that equation
to make things disappear and
and uh one of the things that they found
was like that the flat areas
and also they well the v2 was built
actually by uh
these two um german scientists uh or
aviation guys
um that were um working on it uh what
were their names the uh
there was a there was a team of brothers
and they built the flying wing the first
flying wing
is actually like they were calling it
german stealth technology because
actually
the stealth was actually a byproduct it
wasn't actually an intentional part of
the design they just because they built
a flying wing it didn't have that
long fuselage and that long because
that's where the radar was was bouncing
off of on their planes they found
so they did a lot of research into radar
and radar signal returns
and that's a lot of the research that
was actually done out at area 51
and it was headed by the cia on under a
project called project rainbow
which was headed by a guy named edward
mills purcell and edward mills purcell
was um a physicist who won the nobel
prize in the 60s for discovering nuclear
magnetic resonance
and the fact that atoms are are
basically like spinning magnets and they
have resonances and they have
you know different um different
rotations i got to be honest jeremy
you made an extremely important point
early in the show
and it kind of just uh sucked all the
fun out of it yeah
when you mentioned the need for the
factories to build the nuclear weapons
you know so so i'm not no i'm not i'm
not saying people should build nuclear
weapons let me make my point
you know i said how why can't a 12 year
old have a nuclear bomb he said you
gotta have the factories the refineries
so that means not not it's not
absolutely not necessarily true but
when we're looking for the production of
hovercrafts and ufos and spaceships and
alien tech
you'd see the factories and the industry
you'd see the industrial facilities
you'd recognize them in satellite images
even if they blur them they would still
need way more production facilities
than what we can actually see i think
they're underground i mean
maybe but then it's also the idea is
that
the us has how many factories built
underground to produce this stuff and we
don't see stuff going in or out
like wouldn't we even see where they
were underground they'd have to bring
stuff down there right
i mean we have a massive i mean trillion
dollar military-industrial complex
uh you know budget that of course spends
money
absolutely recklessly and there's
trillions of dollars that's missing who
knows i mean i think it's in the realm
of possibility
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you